REGISTERED A PRELIMINARY
MAGNITUDE OF 7.5.
WE'LL KEEP YOU POSTED.
FINALLY TONIGHT THIS WEEK'S
EDITION OF NOTABLE
>> I JUST HEAR BOOM, BOOM,
BOOM.
AND I WAS JUST LIKE WHAT THE
HECK WAS THAT?
>> WE RECEIVED NO WARNING NO
INDICATION.
>> 2017, THE FBI RECEIVED
INFORMATION I'M GOING TO BE
A PROFESSIONAL SCHOOL
SHOOTER.
>> WE HAVE ALREADY BEGAN TO
DISSECT HIS WEBSITE AND SOME
OF THE THINGS THAT COME TO
MIND ARE VERY, VERY
DISTURBING.
>> THIS MAKES NO SENSE.
MY GIRL, MY 14-YEAR-OLD
BABY.
>> YOUR SUFFERING IS OUR
BURDEN ALSO.
>> I WOULD RATHER PASS GUN
SAFETY THAN THE ELECTION.
>> IN MARCH AND LATE JULY IN
NOE AND JANUARY.
THEY CLEARLY HAVE WORK TO DO
TO FIX THEIR VETTING SYSTEM.
>> I'M TOTALLY OPPOSED TO
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE OF ANY
KIND.
>> KELLY'S JOB.
>> GREAT CONFIDENCE IN THIS
GOOD MAN.
>> ONE OF THE BIGGEST
SPENDING INCREASES IN THE
HISTORY OF THIS COUNTRY AT A
TIME WHEN WE WERE ELECTED TO
DO JUST THE OPPOSITE.
>> FRANKLY, UNITED STATES IS
UNDER ATTACK.
>> IT'S NOT AN OPENING BID
FOR NEGOTIATION, IT'S A BEST
AND FINAL OFFER.
>> NO ONE IS GOING TO GET
EVERYTHING THEY WANT.
>> I THINK IT'S SAFE TO SAY
IT'S BEEN A DISAPPOINTING
WEEK.
>> I TRIED NEGOTIATE SMALLER
EARS, LESS GRAY HAIR.
STRUCK OUT ON THAT AS WELL.
>> Mike: A HEART-BREAKING
WEEK IN PARKLAND, FLORIDA
AND OUR HEARTS AND PRAYERS
ARE WITH THE FAMILIES THERE.